>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
DELAYED HIS FAKE NEWS AWARDS
UNTIL A WEEK FROM WEDNESDAY.
TO WAIT.
WE'LL HAND OUT OUR OWN MEDIA
AWARDS TONIGHT.
THESE ARE JUST FROM THE LAST
TWO DAYS.
WE'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE THE
WORK OF SUCH LUMINARIES CARL
BERNSTEIN AND MIKA BRZEZINSKI.
OUR LACK OF IMPARTIALITY AWARD
GOES TO NBC.
THEY CALLED OPRAH OUR FUTURE
PRESIDENT AND TOOK 14 HOURS TO
TAKE THE TWEET DOWN.
NBC BLAMED SOME MYSTERIOUS
THIRD PARTY FOR POSTING THE
TWEET.
WE WOULDN'T WANT TO GET THE
NETWORK IS ROOTING AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR ANYTHING.
LET'S BRING IN FOX NEWS HOST OF
MEDIA BUZZ, HOWARD KURTZ IN OUR
WASHINGTON STUDIO.
HOWARD, THIS IS LIKE BLAMING
THE INTERN EXCEPT THEY'RE
WHAT IS A THIRD PARTY?
>> I THINK WE NEED A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR.
PARTICULARLY THE OUR PRESIDENT
PART AND THE THING ABOUT IT IS,
YOU KNOW, WHAT THIS SUGGESTS TO
ME IS THE 14-HOUR DELAY.
EITHER NBC EXECUTIVES WERE UP
ALL NIGHT PARTYING AND TOO OUT
OF IT TO DO ANYTHING UNTIL NOON
UNTIL THEY GOT CRITICISM IN THE
PRESS.
>> Jesse: I THINK THE NBC
FRANCHISE SAYS TRUMP TAX CUT
WASN'T GOING TO HELP WORKERS
AND THEN NBC AFTER THE TRUMP
TAX CUT PASSED STARTED GIVING
OUT $1,000 BONUS CHECKS TO
WORKERS FOR CHRISTMAS.
THEY HAVEN'T HAD A GREAT TRACK
RECORD OVER THERE AT NBC.
>> UNLIKE EVERYBODY ELSE IN
TELEVISION.
>> Jesse: WE DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE RATINGS AT ALL.
OTHER WATERGATE REPORTER, THE
ONE WHOSE CAREER TOOK A
DIFFERENT TURN THAT BOB
WOODWARD'S.
SOME PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR WHAT
HE HAS TO SAY.
THIS IS WHY HE WINS OUR WORDS
HAVE NO MEANING AWARD.
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED PLACE.
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH THIS?
ARE WE IN A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS, SPEAKER RYAN, LEADER
MCCONNELL?
WE NEED TO KEEP OUR HEADS DOWN
AND RECOGNIZE WE ARE IN A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS AND WE
HAVE A SPECIAL RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Jesse: DID YOU GET THAT?
THERE IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS.
>> I KIND OF WAS GETTING THAT
IMPRESSION.
CARL BERNSTEIN ATTACKS
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST ABOUT
EVERY DAY OR EVERY WEEK.
HE HAS CALLED HIM A LIAR, HE
HAS CALLED HIM WORSE THAN NIXON
AND TALKED ABOUT THE MALIGNANT
PRESIDENCY AND HE GETS A LOT OF
ATTENTION BECAUSE IT'S THE
WATERGATE AUR YEAH OF WHAT HE
SAYS.
HE WORKED ON THE ORIGINAL STORY
THE THING IS TO COMPARE THOSE
ALLEGATIONS IN THE RUSSIA CASE
TO THE SCANDAL THAT MADE
BERNSTEIN FAMOUS IS A LUDICROUS.
>> Jesse: IF EVERYTHING IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS NOTHING
A TWEET WAS A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS, NOW THE 25th AMENDMENT
WE'LL LOOK AT A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS.
WE GOT IT, CARL, WE GOT IT.
ALL RIGHT.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST THE LACK OF
SELF-AWARENESS AWARD GOES TO
MSNBC MIKA BRZEZINSKI THAT HER
FRIEND'S ATTITUDES MAY REVEAL
SOMETHING ABOUT HER.
SAID THEY WERE JUST EMBARRASSED
THAT IT WAS SORT OF CHILLING.
THAT THEY DIDN'T EVEN WANT TO
SHARE WHERE THEY WERE FROM.
>> Jesse: WELL, I DON'T THINK
WOULD BE SPEAKING GERMAN.
>> I PLAY THAT AS MUCH AS
WHO CONSIDER DONALD TRUMP AN
EMBARRASSMENT.
SHE SAID HARSHER THINGS ABOUT
HIM ON MORNING JOE BUT IT COMES
AFTER A PERIOD OF TIME WHEN SHE
AND JOE SCARBOROUGH HAD A
BITTER FALLING OUT WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR WHOM THEY
HAD BEEN FRIENDLY FOR YEARS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS PERSONALLY
ATTACKED HER, LOW IQ AND ALL
THAT ON TWITTER.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
QUESTION SHE IS SHARING HER
OPINIONS AND YOU AREN'T SHOCKED
SHE HANGS OUT WITH PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HOLD DONALD TRUMP IN THE
HIGHEST REGARD.
>> Jesse: IT SHOWCASES THE
ELITISM.
SHE IS INTERESTING AND LOOKS
LIKE FUN BUT TO TALK ABOUT YOUR
FRIENDS THAT ARE VACATIONING IN
BE AMERICANS.
I JUST DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
REST OF THE AMERICAN AUDIENCE
WHEN THEY SEE HER TALKING LIKE
THAT IF THEY REALLY EVEN CARE
TO RELATE.
I DON'T THINK THEY DO.
>> IT'S LIKE THE FOREIGN
CORRESPONDENT.
I INTERVIEWED THE CAB DRIVER
ABOUT AMERICAN POLITICS.
>> Jesse: IT DOESN'T COME OFF
AS DOWN TO EARTH BUT I DON'T
THINK SHE CARES TO MUCH ABOUT
APPEARING DOWN TO EARTH.